hätten wir diesen himmelskörper in einem
anderen sternensystem aufgespürt wäre
die aufregung groß es könnte wasser
geben und damit die chance auf leben
neben dem mars gibt es nämlich noch
einen planeten beziehungsweise
zwergplaneten der über das wichtigste
element für mögliches leben verfügen
könnte pluto die neuen sensationellen
forschungsergebnisse über den ehemaligen
planeten pluto jetzt in clixoom science
in future los geht's herzlich willkommen
dieses video ist entstanden in
kooperation mit dem digital abos für
smartphone oder tablet für nur regulär 9
eur 99 gibt es nahezu alle magazine und
zeitschriften der link ist hier unter me
mit einem besonders günstigen
sonderangebot für euch hier unter dem
link gibt es den ersten monat umsonst
für euch ab dann neun euro 99 und es
kann jederzeit gekündigt werden und wir
haben dieses mega spannende thema dort
auf wie dede in bild der wissenschaft
gefunden für mich ist wie die idee eine
sprudelnde quelle spannender
wissenschaftsteam hier finde ich in den
relevantesten magazin gut und
verständlich erklärte themen und egal
auf was sich gerade lust habe ich finde
ein magazin es gibt mehr als 5000
magazin auf www de es gibt nichts was es
nicht gibt wheatley ist wie dass netflix
für magazine
bisher galt der zwergplanet pluto als
weitestgehend uninteressant ein felsiger
kleiner klumpen am rande des
sonnensystems der kaum sonnenlicht
abbekommt und deshalb auch erst am 18
februar 1930 entdeckt wurde 85 jahre
später am 14 juli 2015 flog die sonde
new horizons an ihm vorbei und sorgt nun
für eine vollkommen neue sicht auf den
zwergplaneten denn er könnte tatsächlich
wieder saturnmond enceladus ein tiefen
mehr enthalten und damit auch die
möglichkeit von leben bieten aber das
ist noch zukunftsmusik und noch lange
werden wir wohl spekulieren müssen weil
das objekt der begierde rund 40 mal
weiter von der sonne entfernt ist als
die erde
aber die sonde new horizons machte zum
ersten mal sehr detaillierte fotos der
oberfläche und lieferte neue und vor
allem viel detailliertere daten niemand
hätte eine solche biologische vielfalt
auf dem zwergplaneten erwartet
und er verfügt sogar über eine dünne
atmosphäre aus stickstoff und wenig
methan und kohlenmonoxid jetzt kann die
entwicklung von pluto viel besser
eingeschätzt werden
und die war höchstwahrscheinlich heiß
und das ist extrem spannend so
planetenforscher cover ersten von der
university of california in santa cruz
das forschungsteam sich verschiedene
modelle für die entwicklung des plutos
mit den aufnahmen von new horizons ab
den nach zeugen große risse auf der
oberfläche vom pluto von einer
ausdehnung unter der oberfläche durch
einen tiefen ozean der zum teil
zumindest gefrorenes eis bildet ja beim
gefrieren kristalline struktur die das
volumen vom wasser im gegensatz zu
anderen elementen beim übergang in den
festen aggregatzustand anwachsen lässt
heute hat der zwergplanet eine
oberflächentemperatur von rund minus 230
grad celsius doch während der entstehung
müsste er demnach warm gewesen sein
aufgeheizt durch die einschläge von
asteroiden und noch heute könnte der
tiefen ozean in teilen flüssig sein denn
laut simulationsrechnungen eines
japanisch amerikanischen forschungsteams
von 2019 könnten sich zwischen der
eisoberfläche und einem möglichen tiefen
ozean kristalle aus methan und wasser
gebildet haben die den ozean isolieren
jahrmilliarden könnte er so flüssig
bleiben sprich es gibt tatsächlich echte
chancen auf wasser auf dem pluto und es
ist damit ein weiterer himmelskörper mit
einer chance dort leben zu finden was
sich dort vielleicht im laufe von
milliarden in der dunkelheit gebildet
hat doch bis wir dort fündig werden
beziehungsweise überhaupt suchen können
kann es noch sehr sehr lange dauern ganz
sicher wird sich die menschheit jetzt
erst mal auf den mars konzentrieren der
zum einen viel leichter zu erreichen ist
und zum anderen viel mehr indizien für
leben geliefert hat und auch mit seiner
entwicklungsgeschichte und seinen
aktuellen bedingungen die besten
bedingungen für leben bietet bzw geboten
hat und da sind sich viele fachleute
einig aus der astrophysik und aus der
astrobiologie leben zumindest einfache
lebensformen kommen wahrscheinlich
überall im weltall forum wahrscheinlich
auch öfter in unserem sonnensystem oder
bei mars zumindest gab es dort leben
denn und das ist ein entscheidendes
indiz hier auf der erde
wer an den unmöglichsten orten leben
gefunden es gibt lebewesen die bei mehr
als 120 grad celsius existieren oder in
eis in absoluter dunkelheit in saurer
salziger oder basischer umgebung sprich
sie existieren in bedingungen wie sie
auch auf anderen himmelskörpern
herrschen damit scheint eben leben an
ort möglich zu sein die wir noch für
wenig wahrscheinlich halten zumindest im
moment und dazu kommen noch so seltsame
lebewesen wie die bärtierchen die
austrocknen und in eine todes starre
verfallen können und so sind sie sogar
im weltraum überlebensfähig und könnten
von planet zu planet reisen und dort
wieder ein wenig mit wasser benetzt
wieder zum leben erwachen hier auf der
erde gehören sie jedenfalls zu den
ersten tieren so dokumentieren es
fossilen funde aus dem erdaltertum das
sind alles bisher bloße hypothesen wenn
wir also eine ähnliche spezies auf einem
anderen himmelskörper hier im
sonnensystem finden würden dann wäre das
absolut bahn brechen und dann wäre leben
tatsächlich an allen möglichen ort
möglich an denen es nur einigermaßen
lebensfreundliche bedingungen gibt also
auch temperaturen über 100 und unter
null grad celsius es bleibt spannend wie
auch in all den zeitschriften auch rita
de
wie schon öfter stammt das thema von
dort wheatley nutze ich inzwischen schon
seit einigen jahren weil man da wirklich
nahezu alles findet wie zum beispiel
hier das meer in plutos unterwelt in
bild der wissenschaft allein für diese
zeitschrift lohnt sich schon dass die
idee abo und was ich besonders gut finde
es ist papier frei kein einziger baum
wird gerodet aber auf weg.de gibt es
noch weitere mehr als 5000 magazine das
sonderangebot für euch gibt es hier
einfach draufklicken der link ist
übrigens auch in der video beschreibung
also drauf klicken und los geht's bis
dann bleibt dran